do you remember the first time you saw a
dinosaur for kids who grow up loving
dinosaurs the Jurassic movies are really
the vehicle for them to see their dreams
realize the Jurassic movies have always
been suspenseful and exciting we're
telling the next chapter this story
takes dinosaurs and takes Jurassic where
it's never gone before
or literally blowing up the island
in this movie we have a new director
Juan Antonio Bayona I love playing with
suspense
I like intensity and I love to make the
audience feel the total experience he's
genius when it comes to frightening
people mr. X careful dinosaurs
everywhere and they're flipping out and
killing people let's go it was important
to us that the story be balanced on the
characters some of whom we know and some
of whom were just meeting Jeff Goldblum
not gonna lie that's pretty awesome Here
I am talking about dinosaurs again this
drastic world you will see more
dinosaurs than you've ever seen before
on this movie we are dealing with real
animatronic dinosaurs it looks like a
real dinosaur I couldn't help but freak
out the entire time
the challenge of making a sequel is
finding the right balance between what
people are expecting and what people
will be surprised by
this movie is different it's going to be
intense and free spectacular
[Music]
that was my best acting
it's like nothing you've ever seen
before
yeah man it's Jurassic
this is gonna be awesome
[Music]
you